no i just actually want to say so when i
when i when we saw the shark tank
episode yeah you know how like because
you guys watch that even before you're
on yeah you know the kind where someone
comes out with a product or service and
you me and it depends on who you are
obviously right and you immediately know
like oh this guy's gonna get a deal yep
that's what i felt about yours because
brad he bet you don't watch shark tank
i've watched it i mean i watched your
episodes over the past like a few days
when i knew you were coming out here but
no i'm not a regular watcher bro i'm
like like a bunch of other people the
moment i saw that thing
as a i was like did you know anything
about did you know eli before that no no
i didn't this was back in the days like
in 2014 yeah
um but bro once i saw that thing i was
like bro that's the coolest i've
ever seen yeah you're that guy bro oh
yeah you're that guy that he was talking
about no dude it was i mean it was so it
was so cool and such a blessing man and
uh i mean it's still
i tell people all the time you know
you know guys don't really grow up we
just get bigger toys can i tell can i
tell the sal defranco story oh yeah
all right so it's so funny man
you know jocko is who jocko is man and
you know you got got people that want to
be like jocko right and it just so
happened that a lot of people you know
in in task unit 2 wanted to be like
jocko so
they made us do the older guys made the
younger guys do skits
and that's a pretty dicey situation man
because by the way i know i know where
sal lives right now yeah i know where
he's at so i might have to go get him so
he's coming brother no um
he wasn't even making fun of you
really it was just he was making fun of
people that wanted to be like you
and so it was funny so they they make
you do these skits and if you piss them
off you know you deal with you deal with
that side of it but if you make them if
you can make them laugh while making fun
of them that's that's the the golden
ticket right so
sal was always the funniest dude so sal
came up with a lot a lot of our skits
and so
um i remember he did this skit and it
was like he was playing you
and uh or no he was playing i think he's
playing stoner and he had this he had
this note like this nope this binder and
he put like
uh what was it
www jd what would jocko do and he like
walks out playing stoner talking like
stoner he's like you know all the
acronyms btf charlie mike you know the
guys are just rolling because he's you
know he's like you know making fun of
all these guys who want to be like jocko
but are failing miserably and it was
just it was just so funny dude so you
know that that became you know a joke
you know a running joke after you left
like
god dude all these guys walking around
what would jocko do trying to be like
bro you're not joking just be yourself
man okay just for yourself
big tough frog man you know
over 200 pounds all this stuff dude
hey what's charlie mike
continue mission oh yeah that's just
another right and it and it's a
unofficial thing
meaning
uh our status this time is that we are
going to charlie mike i mean it's an
official thing like we are actually
continuing the mission but that turns
into just like uh hey just charlie mike
bro you just gotta just keep going
vtf not official btf is unofficial
official yeah okay
btf is unofficial similar meaning except
for btf has
you know greater capabilities because it
can be used for a lot more things than
just
continue mission
so you know um that's all good it's all
good